a minnesota-based company is bringing
high-speed internet access to areas in
the valley largely ignored by big
providers they identify themselves as a
disrupter in the industry today they
were at a mobile home park near Nellis
and Boulder Highway Joshua peguero was
there as several people signed up for
the new service
during the pandemic quick bit saw an
opportunity to help kids in remote
learning with bad internet connection
and remote workers dealing with their
Zoom calls dropping
over 22 million people live in mobile
home parks in the United States of
America if it was a state it would be
the third largest state in the United
States and yet they have terrible
internet not on average almost
exclusively terrible internet
the company was at Pueblo Del Sol mobile
home park persuading residents to drop
their current Internet providers and
offers equally fast upload and download
speeds for a monthly flat fee of fifty
dollars and twenty dollars based on a
certain income threshold that appealed
to Robin Jones I want to fix anything
I'm retired I'm on the plane a third
more half as much more or twice as much
as I originally go for it once a person
signs up for their service it usually
takes half about an hour and an hour and
a half to come install it and they're
guaranteed to get the internet for free
for three months with no contract some
internet companies don't service mobile
home parks which ends up impacting
residents like Jones so I think if
they're neglecting us as a demographic
then they're missing out a lot
quitbit is currently in eight states and
are at one other mobile home park in Las
Vegas the infrastructure bill passed by
Congress in 2021 has 65 billion dollars
in it for Broadband funding yeah Joe
Costello says government agencies are
too slow to act no one should go out
without good energy there's no excuse we
can make it happen today we can make it
happen very economically and very
quickly it's not something that has to
happen 10 years from now Fitbit does it
need to install Fiber Optic Cables it
only takes them three days to put up
equipment that can hook up mobile homes
with Wi-Fi reporting between Nellis and
Boulder Highway Joshua peguero eight
news now
and quitbit will be in Reno next week to
install its Wi-Fi at a mobile home park
in Northern Nevada